it's something we're going back to the
beginning of equity investing etc right
in in terms of when people first art
investing in companies there was no such
thing as liquidity preferences or
shareholder rights etc but you actually
had the bare instrument yes yeah you
actually owned your your shares and so
we've almost come full circle to the
extent just now in the digital world
right and so how do you see that ripple
impact across Wall Street right if the
retail investors are willing to do this
without going through financial
institutions yeah
does that force the financial
institutions to you know kind of move in
this direction as well or do you think
that they can hold out
oh I there they're going to be forced to
move in this direction because they're
just gonna be disintermediated and
what's fascinating to me is that there
are there's a whole parallel
infrastructure of of Wall Street right
there are structures of these capital
raises we call him I SEOs but they can
be security token offerings whatever you
want to call it there there's a whole
capital market that's built up around
around these products so you've got that
you've got the advisors you've got the
exchanges you've got research firms that
that specialize in all of this and and
Wall Street is gonna get to sooner
mediated by them and the thing that they
cannot that Wall Street does not offer
right now and frankly isn't set up very
well to do it is to be able to build
tech you don't have people who can
design an ER c20 token and understand
how to market at an IC Ora Ora or an sto
out to the investor universe that's not
something Wall Street can do but I've
had a number of companies talk to me
about corporate coins corporate ERC 20
tokens and I think it's very real it's
as I've said in one of the forbes.com
pieces it this is actually I think
cheaper capital it's it's securitization
by another name and so for a company to
go out and raise capital that way is
very rational and and I think that
they're gonna find cheaper capital
either for startups and we've seen that
right the the the amount of VC
investment in this industry compared to
the token investment in this industry
you know the tokens surpassed VC
investment in
octane 18 months ago but now the whole
token industry is 30 percent of what VC
traditional VC across the board not just
blockchain right this is it's already
happening that's already
disintermediating and and it's 45
percent of the size of the IPOs in in
the first quarter oh sorry sorry in the
second quarter and 41 percent I think
was the number in the first quarter so
it wasn't just a flash in the pan it's
we've had six months of you know that
this this token market has raised a very
material amount of capital institutional
sized and that is attracting companies
to this market I think we're gonna see
you know more than just the Kodak coin
absolutely well it in you know I think a
lot about like this power shift right so
if you think of when investing first
started the founders or owners of the
business had a lot of the power yet so
they would go to people and say hey give
me money and you'd have a claim on my
cash flow over time investors realize
hey we have money and so we have we've
got some leverage here and they
continued to kind of ratchet down on
business owners or founders and now what
we're seeing is a shift in power back to
those founders and entrepreneurs because
what we're doing is on a global basis
you just open it up there's always an
investor who's willing to take less
egregious terms yeah but I also think
that it is a trade a trade off right the
markets actually been pretty good at
weeding out the scams so you know that's
one of the one of the benefits of crypto
Twitter is that you know people are
ruthless and and and so if it's just an
outright scam so but I think there's a
difference because I think the detail
your measure so there's a difference
between a scam yeah and let's say a
founder who says look when I raise
capital I'm looking for two things I see
for money and I'm looking for help yeah
right and so if I believe that there's
an investor who will give me money and
help but the terms are erroneous right
or kind of egregious then I'm willing to
open that up to a wider set of investors
to find a better market equilibrium for
what this round pricing should be
absolutely and I think one of the
interesting things that comes out of
that is that this is a big competitive
threat to the state of Delaware and
having worked when I while I was at
Symbian symbionts it was simians idea to
go start the Delaware blockchain
initiative marks
got that done before I got to Simeon and
we were gung-ho moving forward with the
former governor and then the incumbents
came in and then threw sand in the
wheels under the new governor and and
and and here's the irony based on what I
suggest announced that it's going to
natively digital assets it just takes
away Delaware's competitive advantage I
don't see any reason why a company in a
start-up would register in Delaware why
because of exactly what you just talked
about they now have a capital markets
alternative where they don't have they
don't have to go and be a Delaware
corporation where investors really are
comfortable with the state of Delaware
because the law is most defined there
there's great case law there's the
Delaware Chancery Court all those things
fit the traditional corporate equity
issuance and preferred share venture
capital funding model but now if you can
actually issue tokens you're just gonna
have a very different-looking balance
sheet you're just gonna have a big
contingent liability on your balance
sheet but it doesn't matter where you
what you organize as a company because
you're not raising capital by selling
equity you're raising capital through
this securitization type secured
financing type of vehicle which means
that Delaware law is not a competitive
advantage at all and I find that it's
just disappointing Delaware squandered
it's it's it's huge head start were two
and a half years after the announcement
of the Delaware blockchain initiative
and of course they were working on it
before it wasn't before Governor Mark
Hamill announced it at consensus in 2016
in that was I think April and and and
they are just maybe later this year I
think going to have a prototype to
consider at the state of Delaware so I
mean it's just it's it's pretty clear
what happened there yeah